where in the world is that kamala harris
it's been more than a week since
president biden told us she would
spearhead the crisis
on our southern border and yet she
hasn't gone to the region she hasn't
held a press conference and the biden
administration's response to this
humanitarian crisis is just awol
according to cnn
of all places the vp is fired up about a
different crisis
renovations at the vice presidential
mansion are behind schedule and she is
quote
getting frustrated and sick of living
out of a suitcase and
at the blair house which is a different
mansion on the other side of town
so her suitcase is already packed why
doesn't she just leave her mansion
and go visit the children living in
squalor without clean clothes
at the border do you have plans to visit
the border
not today but
i have before and i'm sure i will again
joining me now is kaylee mcenany former
white house press secretary
and a fox news analyst uh welcome to the
show
kaylee and congratulations on your new
job on outnumber we're so proud to have
you part of the family
um thank you very much well let's just
talk about this because she's definitely
awol
and you know there's all this confusion
about her job and what she's doing and
she's changing it i feel like she's
trying to distance herself maybe
wash her hands from this whole thing
because she knows this is going
nowhere and it's bad
rachel you hit the nail on the head i
mean look we were told a week ago by
president biden that
quote the most qualified person most
qualified
to stem the tide of illegal immigration
to our southern border
is vice president kamala harris here we
are a week out and all of a sudden
she seems to have tossed this problem
back to joe biden after the headlines
came out like the one from politico that
joe biden handed kamala harris a grenade
a political grenade well she tossed that
grenade
right back to him because for kamala
harris this was about having latitude
without the blame and what i mean is the
latitude to reach out to foreign leaders
without accepting the blame when the
ill-advised biden policy or lack thereof
lack of a plan goes south as it already
has and you have to wonder if she's
actually speaking to those leaders
because
the president of mexico is not happy
with what's happened he actually really
liked the way
donald trump was doing and he was
cooperating with the country to stem the
tide of people
coming from central america i mean they
weren't coming because they didn't want
to get stuck
in mexico it was a brilliant policy it
was a brilliant policy exactly and you
had
an unlikely ally and uh in the mexican
president there with president trump
and i say unlikely they were at
different ends of the political spectrum
but had a great partnership in stopping
uh this crisis on the southern border
and styming illegal immigration and then
you have joe biden come in
and the mexican president good for him
says this is the migrant president he's
responsible and deserves the blame for
what's happening
on the southern border i'm paraphrasing
him but that's in essence what he said
because he saw the great work that can
be done
with the agreements we made with the
northern triangle countries and the
trump administration that joe biden for
whatever reason
came in and ripped up and incentivized
what we're seeing which is not humane
there was video that fox just put up
of um two young girls a three-year-old
and a five-year-old girl that border
patrol put out and fox highlighted
being left in the in the new mexico
desert after being dropped over a
14-foot barrier
this is inhumane it's sad and it's been
incentivized by joe biden and kamala
harris yeah there was a little
nine-year-old girl who was drowned
also it's just um it's just so
heartbreaking
um equally heartbreaking is the
situation in san diego where we have
parents who for a year have not had any
in-person instruction for their children
at the school and then they find out
that
hey the teachers are volunteering to go
down to
teach in person down at the border and
it's weird because the whole reason they
said they weren't going to teach the
kids
in san diego was because they said they
didn't feel safe but the covid rates are
higher
among the border children yeah that's
right
and in fact in that san diego facility
there were about 700 children there 82
of which tested positive for kovitz
that's roughly
one and eight testing positive for covid
and you have teachers volunteering to go
in person there
but yet we know in these perfectly safe
schools that oftentimes
that that do use distancing that do have
these protocols in place that the cdc
put out guidelines back in the trump
administration and these schools have
been equipped with money
and technology uh and and ways to keep
our kids safe and we know they're not
super spreader events but they won't go
there to teach
us citizen children although you have
some volunteering to go into a place
where one in eight illegal immigrants
are testing positive for covet it's a
huge disparity
yeah well it's interesting the irony
today by the way is cesar chavez day
he's a labor activist very famous labor
activist who's passed away now but today
is his day
there's actually a bust of cesar chavez
in the
biden oval office and so today jill went
to celebrate that but
it's such a weird thing because cesar
chavez was a labor activist he actually
was very much opposed to open borders
he sent people down to the border
including himself we went down
to try and block it i think if cesar
chavez was alive today
he would be a hundred percent against
what the
the biden administration is doing i
think he would bring the labor activists
who know their jobs are going to be
you know lower wages because of all of
this influx of
of people from south and central america
i think he'd be down there trying to
close the border
yeah it's a really great point i mean we
knew where he stood on these issues and
you've got to wonder
uh someone who was so avidly opposed to
illegal immigration because it
it would uh it would have the american
workers suffer
especially low-income workers here in
the united states someone who was so
fervent on that point
how would he feel in the middle of a
global pandemic when you had president
trump who said
you know i'm going to stop h-1b visas
and non-agricultural temporary workers
because we've got to protect american
workers in the middle of a global
pandemic with lockdowns pretty sure
chavez would have been on this side
absolutely well kayla you always have a
lot to say because you have so much
experience from your white house days
we're so happy to have you on the fox
family thank you rachel all right thank
you for joining me